>> THE FORMER CIA DIRECTOR'S
TWEET IS INSANE TO ANYONE MONTH
HAS A BRAIN.
YEAH, FORMER DIRECTOR MICHAEL
HAYDEN STARTED IN BRITISH RETURN
GIST EDWARD LUCE TWEETED.
TO WHICH HAYDEN REPLIED, I AGREE
AND I WAS THE CIA DIRECTOR.
NOW, SOMEWHERE THERE'S AN AL
QUEDA GOING HOW MANY GOATS DO WE
NEED TO BANK AROUND HERE?
HOW MANY MORE TIMES DO I NEED TO
GET [BLEEP] BEFORE AL QUEDA GETS
RESPECT AROUND HERE.
MADE THAN SEEMED TO ENDORSE THE
EXECUTION OF TRUMP.
HAYDEN THINKS HALF OF AMERICA IS
WORSE THAN THE TERRORIST HE
KILLED.
WHAT WOULD HE RECOMMEND HERE,
TAKE OUT THE RNC WITH A CLUSTER
BOMB DRONE STRIKE OUR NATION'S
GOLF COURSES?
IF REPUBLICANS ARE THE MOST
DANGEROUS GROUP A FORMER CIA
DIRECTOR HAS SEEN MAYBE THE CIA
ISN'T PROTECTING US FROM REAL
THREATS.
BUT IT BACKS UP WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN SAYING FOR YEARS.
IF YOU BELIEVE TRUMP WAS WORSE
THAN HITLER YOU COULD BREAK THE
LAW TO STOP HIM.
HENCE THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
>> WHATEVER JOE BIDEN'S
CORRUPTION IS IT IS TINY
COMPARED TO THE CORRUPTION WE
KNOW TRUMP IS INVOLVED IN.
IT DOESN'T EVEN STACK UP AGAINST
TRUMP UNIVERSITY.
TRUMP AUFRTS A STORY IS WORSE
THAN ANYTHING THAT WOULD BE IN
HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP.
>> YEAH, OKAY.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST HARRIS.
HERE IS SKULL FACE.
>> PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN AND HAVE THE
RIGHT TO STORM THE CAPITOL WHICH
IS A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
ARE EVIL.
RACISM IS EVIL.
MISOGYNY IS EVE.
>> THAT WAS SAD.
AFTER THAT HE SHED HIS SKIN AND
ATE A MONGOOSE.
>> YOU ALWAYS WERE SAYING I
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO HIDE.
>> THAT'S NOT HOW I SOUND.
>> THAT'S HOW IT SOUNDED TO ME.
>> I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
BUT I'VE ALWAYS KNOWN I WAS
RIGHT.
>> OH, GOOD FOR YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
BUT OF COURSE, I MEAN IT'S
GIVING PEOPLE POWER TO BE ABLE
TO WE WILL IN POLITICAL WAYS AND
ESPECIALLY FOR THEM TO MAKE
THESE STATEMENTS WITHOUT ANY
EVIDENCE TO BACK IT UP.
THE ONLY THING THEY POINTED TO
WAS JANUARY 6th BUT THAT WAS
LIKE 2000 PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT QUITE A MAJORITY OF
REPUBLICANS.
>> AND IT'S OUT OF THE 2,000,
PERHAPS 200 WHATEVER WERE
IDIOTS.
PROBABLY MORE.
>> I DON'T KNOW ANY OF THEM
PERSONALLY.
>> I THOUGHT THEY HAD WERE ALL
LIVING WITH YOU.
TYRUS, IT'S CRAZY.
THIS GUY DRONED TERRORISTS AND
IS SAYING REPUBLICANS ARE WORSE.
>> THIS IS A COMPLIMENT.
WHAT IS THE SAFEST GROUP TO TALK
TRASH ABOUT AND POSSIBLY GET ON
TV?
REPUBLICANS.
>> EXACTLY.
>> YOU SAY THAT STUFF TO ANTIFA.
HE'S OUT AFTER JOB TRYING TO GET
RELEVANT.
ALL OF A SUDDEN HEY, GUESS WHO
IS THE MOST DANGEROUS PERSON ON
THE PLANET.
G.O.P.
THEN SOMEBODY WILL RESPOND
SAYING IT WAS UNFAIR AND UNKIND.
DO YOU HAVE ANY STATS TO SUPPORT
THAT?
AND HE WILL SMILE AND GO THAT'S
WHY YOU'RE THE MOST DANGEROUS
PERSON THERE IS BECAUSE YOU'RE
GOING TO COME BACK WITH THINGS
LIKE THAT AND IT'S THE SAME
THING WITH THE GUY WHO WAS LIKE,
I HATE WHAT ABOUTISMS.
LET'S SAY TRUMP IS EVERYTHING HE
CLAIMS HE IS.
DOES THAT MAKE BIDEN'S
CORRUPTION LESS?
HE ONLY KILLED FOUR GUYS MANY
TRUMP KILLED EIGHT.
YOU'RE BOTH MURDERERS THAT THE
DOESN'T EXCUSE WHAT HE'S DOING.
THAT'S HOW THEY DEFEND ANYTHING.
BUT THE AMAZING THING TRUMP HAS
BEEN TRIED 75,000 TIMES AND
KEEPS WALKING WAY UNSKAIDZED
LIKE THE TEFLON PRESIDENT WHERE
THEY WON'T PUT THIS GUY MONTH
QUESTION BECAUSE IT GOES BACK TO
THE SAME THING.
HE'S OUT OF WORK, DESPERATE,
G.O.P., HOPEFULLY SOMEBODY LIKE
TRUMP WILL FIRE BACK ON HIM.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS?
HE GETS ON THE SHOW.
YOU BRING HIM BACK AND HE'S GOT
MORE EXPERT [BLEEP] AND NO ONE
IS GOING TO HURT HIM FOR IT.
>> BUNCH OF GUYS IN POLO SHIRTS
AND GOAT SHOES.
>> IT'S CREEPY THIS GUY WAS CIA
DIRECTOR AND HAD THESE FEELINGS.
MAKES YOU THINK THERE WAS OTHER
STUFF GOING ON THAT WE DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT.
>> HOW MUCH TRUST CAN WE LOSE?
THESE TWO GUYS FOR TYRUS'S POINT
ARE HANGING ON.
I FEEL BETTER FOR THEM.
WHEN THEY GET OLDER AND DON'T
HAVE IMPORTANT POSITIONS THEY
WANT TO BE IN THE LIMELIGHT
AGAIN AND SAY SOMETHING.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S K-RAILS
RHETORIC HE'S GOT GOING ON AND
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING TO HELP THIS
COUNTRY AND YOU KNOW, WE WANT TO
GET BACK TO POSITIVE STUFF.
I LIKED CARVILLE.
HE'S KIND OF A FUNNY GUY.
>> HE'S MARRIED A REPUBLICAN.
>> HE SAYS THAT ABOUT
REPUBLICANS BUT HE ALSO TEARS
DOWN DEMOCRATS IN THIS STORY AND
REGULARLY.
HE CALLS THEM DUFUSES OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO I LIKE A
STRAIGHT TALK GUY LIKE HIM BUT
THIS WENT ON 30 MINUTES AND I
DON'T THINK HAD ANY OF YOU
WATCHED THE WHOLE 30 MINUTES.
>> I JUST WATCHED IT THE FIRST
TIME.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
>> NOBODY DOES.
NOBODY DOES.
BUT GOOD FOR YOU CARVILLE, ROCK
ON.
NOBODY CARES.
>> LAST WORDS FROM YOU, WHAT DO
YOU MAKE FROM THIS?
>> IT'S A PLAYBOOK.
IT'S A POLITICAL CLIMATE.
WE ARE IN MIDTERMS A FEW MONTHS
WADE AND TWO MORE YEARS WE WILL
BE HEARING THIS AGAIN.
THIS IS WHAT THEY CALL
REPUBLICANS RACIST STUPID JOHN
CARVILLE CALLING US STUPID,
JAMES CARVILLE CALLING US STUPID
SO I MADE A LIST WHAT'S STUPID.
PULLING TROOPS OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN BEFORE YOU PULL OUT
THE ALLIES MANY SPENDING
BILLIONS TO HIRE MORE IRS AGENTS
IN THE MIDDLE OF INFLATION AN
RECESSION.
DEFUNDING POLICE, WHY DO YOU
THINK CRIME IS UP?
OPEN BORDERS DON'T
CZECHOSLOVAKIA'S CARDS AT THE
BORDER BUT DJOKOVIC CAN'T PLAY
IN THE U.S. OPEN?
THAT'S STUPID.
CLOSING THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE,
THAT'S JUST A FEW.
>> IT'S ALL STUPID.
ALL RIGHT.
[APPLAUSE]
.